l'entrée sous les escaliers c'est
terminé le musée de la ville a intégré
ses nouveaux locaux à deux pas nous
voici dans le nouveau musée de la ville
de saint quentin en yvelines
alors nouveau parce que c'est un nouveau
lieu d'abord on emménage dans l'est dans
le bâtiment qui abrite la médiathèque du
canal c'est aussi un nouvel aménagement
intérieur avec des espaces et des
contenus complètement repensé plus de
280 mètres carrés trois espaces pour
quelques-uns des 6000 objets de la
collection des espaces plus lumineux et
plus accessible à tous le nouveau musée
est de plain pied
il y avait besoin de doubler cet espace
parce que celui du musée était devenu
vraiment très restreint dans l'ancien
musée
ça fait plaisir de voir un an et demi de
travail de travaux aussi qu'ils
aboutissent et qui aboutissent avait
vraiment quelque chose de concret on a
hâte que les visiteurs reviennent et
rendre sa vie au musée surface plus
grande dit aussi exposition repenser la
permanente qui retrace l'histoire de
l'agglomération de saint quentin en
yvelines voies plus larges de la
préhistoire à nos jours
s'il est de niveau intercommunal c'est
qu'en fait il retrace bien toute
l'histoire de la ville et en plus ils
portent le label art et riche histoire
et en fait on s'aperçoit et vous l'avez
vu au début de l'exposition
en fait les villages avaient une origine
historique importante est simple c'est
bien de rappeler tout ça et on en même
temps montre toutes les toute
l'évolution puis comme ça on tient
compte aussi un petit peu de l'évolution
du territoire puisqu'on vient d'intégrer
5 5 une nouvelle ville une exposition
temporaire est proposée en parallèle une
chaque année le musée a tiré avant sa
fermeture environ dix mille visiteurs
par an dès le 25 janvier les huit
membres de l'équipe seront prêts à les
accueillir de nouveaux